chaque endroit une fois tous les quatre
ans des conférences des démonstrations
pratiques pendant deux jours eric
guillonneau aura accepté que son domaine
d'une oeuvre en accueille des dizaines
de confrères et consoeurs paraît chez
moi j'aime beaucoup et échanges
je vais beaucoup dans les formations
parce que je trouve que tout le monde
peut nous apporter quelque chose chacun
peut apporter quelque chose et
on est dans un monde quand même rural et
on se doit de tout s'entraider et ce fut
donc à festival du maraîchage bio le
premier du genre consacrée au bio
intensif de mots qui n'ont rien de
contradictoire c'est un peu la logique
du maraîchage bio intensif c'est de
concentrer les énergies sur une petite
surface et c'est les projets de beaucoup
de porteurs de projets actuellement ce
que l'accès au foncier est pas toujours
évident voyez mail agnellini 15 ans de
recherche en immunologie et maintenant
le retour à la terre en beauce mais pas
en grandes cultures en maraîchage bio
intensifs
c'est travailler sur une petite surface
et produire beaucoup de légumes et donc
avoir des connaissances techniques je
pense très très bas il ya les techniques
et les outils de ces techniques
tout dépend de ses moyens au sommet du
confort ya ce tracteur tout électrique
pas de pollution pas de bruit et 100%
made in france
plus modeste ce petit robot va tout de
même remplacé les herbicides chimiques
c'est un petit appareil qui sert à faire
du binage donc à passer entre les plants
forestiers du moins sur l'intérieur on
peut faire plusieurs atterrant 4,5 10
suivant en nombre et en fait il est
complètement autonome il va tourner tout
seul
puis économique encore cette bineuse
désherbeur à tout aussi bien sans
obliger le maraîcher à s'accroupir entre
les rangs alors adapter à des petites
surfaces adaptées des petits budget
aussi beaucoup de petits maraîchers
petite surface d'un hectare voire moins
d'accord donc grande diversité aussi
dans le maraîchage diversité de légumes
voit la diversité le sol aussi on
parlait bien d'une d'une lan qui va
mieux sur un terrain sur un autre voilà
un robot savez 1,01 ou maraîchère toute
équipe et j'en ai pour 800 euros et
enfin voilà et puis adapté à chaque
morphologie aussi on parle beaucoup
d'économies maraîchage car ce sont
surtout des paysans qui ont échangé
leurs expériences et des outils nouveaux
voici le paper potes qui permet de
dérouler des plans de requêtes en
épargnant de la fatigue et du temps de
travail
on s'est fini le temps on était des
paysans a bossé 70 80 heures semaine on
a tous envie d'avoir une vie de famille
les loisirs on a aussi d'autres centres
d'intérêts qui peuvent être militant
culturel ou hot suivant les gens quand
on fait 80 heures semaine on peut pas on
peut pas faire ce à quoi donc
voilà le beaucoup de maraîchers
recherche différentes solutions pour
être plus efficace - sert mal et puis
tout en respectant le sol et la qualité
des légumes en cours six ans après son
installation le tourangeau fabien jobard
tous qui faisait 6 démonstration d'un
outil de récolte du mesclun vie bien de
ce bio intensifs je vend sous forme
d'amap donc sous forme de paniers fait
70 paniers par semaine et j'arrive à me
dégager une rémunération d'environ 1500
euros par mois ce qui est plutôt par
alia des producteurs qui sont beaucoup
plus gros qui vendent beaucoup plus de
légumes et qui viennent moins bien leur
vie et plus on sera deux petits
maraîchers sur petites surfaces à vendre
localement à des familles ou sur des
marchés et plus on s'en portera vers
pour l'heure la région centre val de
loire compte près de 200 maraîcher bio
et pour la seule année à venir il
devrait être 20 de plus